yes but it was roughly when I was about
eight that I basically said you know I
wish I was a girl when he was 8 years
old when I was 8 years old what do you
know if there was any specific factors
that made you say that was it random was
it was it like I I want to be a girl a
lot of it was societal do you go to
female toilet or male toilets oh I just
go to the toilet I tend to go I go to
female toilets when I'm out okay but
that for for example a lot of people
will have a lot of concerns with that
cuz if I'm saying to my daughter let me
tell you why not that I'm not saying
that I'm not saying that your already is
Lish that there are male and females
there are some people who say there are
no male or females okay then then what
do we say to them somebody who believes
and says I don't believe there are men
and women there are social constructs
well that's what they are okay so then
how do you now how do you believe their
reality okay but how do you believe
their reality because you said we do
cats canc know it's a male's braid and a
female's braid but somebody come and say
you know hold I don't believe there are
men and women are two
[Music]
we want to establish an amazing Masjid
for the sake of Allah subhana tala in
the country of Norway click on the link
and donate now for the sake of Allah
subhana wa tala and so they walked away
and this guy is just accident you know
just happens to have an apple in his bag
and he's taking out of his bag and about
27 okay you know so
from my point of view I'm I believe what
I'm saying when I see say that true
based on what you can observe yeah now
that I'm wrong doesn't mean that you
know is not the same thing as you know
being right or you know so it's not the
uh the it's more nebulous isn't it okay
all right so you said 6 years ago you
transitioned yeah you you are Laura now
I am yes okay you was uh well the thing
about it I don't use my old name okay
things very mind I was um I was already
always a girl up here I just withheld it
because I didn't I didn't what made you
what made you I'm was 51 years old okay
okay when I was eight yeah I think I was
roughly when I was about eight you know
when you're when you're young you you
know memories a bit vague but it was
roughly when I was about eight that I
basically said you know I wish I was a
girl when he was 8 years old when I was
8 years old what do you know if there
was any specific factors that made you
say that was was it random was it was it
like I I want to be a girl a lot of it
was
societal so um my parents were in the
military okay and when you're in
military life um everything is kind of
organized you know I mean my like say my
parents were in the Air Force okay you
can imagine November the 5th where we
got the fireworks right well when you've
got guys that work with ammunition and
bombs you can imagine the kind of fun
that they can have when they can build
build them you know so uh it's you know
it was something to you know the kind of
firew display we see is like nothing to
military guys you anyway so um one year
we did a maple dance do you know maple
dance is no what is it um it's like a
pole yeah and it's got ribbons different
colors okay and then you sort of dancing
P you know and it wraps it up and
everything it's a sort of you know old
okay it's probably Pagan in his history
I was going to ask you to show me the
dance but you probably forgot no
possibly but uh anyway the the um you
know the point of it is that um uh that
I take BTO I wasn't enjoying myself
because when you're eight yeah um it's
that age of girls you know and dancing
that's a girls thing so there was that
sort of male Le okay yeah okay but I
like the dancing you like the dancing I
like the dancing I liked it you know did
you say would you say you liked it
because is that way you felt like you
were a girl or is it cuz it was
associated with girls I think it was in
my first thoughts of that what's the
girls thing do you think that could have
triggered cuz you know what it is
sometimes like sometimes there are men
who have thoughts of
homosexuality it's just a proping
thought it's not the same thing and then
they think oh I must be gay no no no
it's an identity
thing okay how did you how do you
establish that cuz at 8 years old you're
mus how you know you're a Muslim I
became a Muslim 11 years ago so I
submitted to the fact that there is one
God is the final mess like uh do you
have a favorite ice cream yes okay uh
yeah why
uh because I tast you like the taste of
it I tasted it and then I came to know
that I like that yeah so it's experience
based okay okay now um being trans is
not the same as gay isn't the same it's
not on the same league as homosexuality
even though it's LGBT yes okay and the
reason for that is that it's an identity
thing how I think of myself as the world
you know in the world you know that I'm
a like you know that I've got five
fingers four fingers and a thumb that
subjective it is
subjective aren't all these things are
subjective yeah so for example if I say
that I identify as a pirate yep and I
say to myself you know what in order for
me to be a pirate I have to have a
missing left arm and a missing right leg
oh I'm sorry argum no no no I could just
SW you said parent and I'm thinking
wait pirate a pirate yeah exactly so if
I was to say I identify where do we draw
the line because to us in the Quran for
example God Almighty says if you forget
my meance I will make you forget your
own self now for me obviously I have no
evidence or case study for this but what
we believe is that if anyone doesn't
have a relationship with God Almighty
then we go down the route of trying to
seek happiness through other means and
what this means is that we don't have a
limit now this is the reason why the era
that we're living in we've got people
who are identifying as pianos you got
people identif as a tree there's people
identifying as a c where do we draw the
draw the line for yourself for example
I've course you was 8 years old there
was a specific dance you wanted to do
and that was I that was in um was The
Awakening of this is who I am but how
how did you come to cuz you know what is
I'm just trying to understand your
psychology where did you come 6 years
ago why did it take you 6 years because
you said at the age of eight you had
this tendency to be want to be in the
girl well the problem is you just sort
of go along with the but why because if
that is your identity why would you
delay that identity for such decades and
then six years later embrace it and say
I'm going to be
Laura effectively all these things are
human M structures okay we we tag these
words so we can fit into a nice box so
you know we like to say that's a tall
person that's a fat person that's a him
you know um all sorts of things you know
they have big feet they have red hair
yes uh you know all these elements we we
adopt these categories yes in order to
make sense of things cuz at the end of
the day it comes down to human The Human
Condition okay yeah so let's just go
basic language okay so you I'm guessing
you know two languages at least right
yeah yeah yeah yeah so um you know
Pakistani I'm Turkish so oh Turkish okay
so Turkish I love Pakistani okay so
basically you're Persian yeah again that
is another tag you know what's the
difference between Persian and and
Middle Eastern you know it's effectively
narrowing it down and it's wrapped in
all sort things culture language
structure you know so on so uh you know
even LS um well we can't we can't
biologically like when we look at
someone biology we cannot determine
where they are kind of from they can get
an idea from it but for example
biologically you would understand that
for example for you to identify as a
woman we know that biologically a woman
gives birth and she had different
reproduction system okay so if you got a
woman that's sterile and she can't give
birth is she's not a woman anymore no no
no but we know she has the ability to
give birth but she doesn't she's sterile
she doesn't have the ability maybe she
was born with a whip what maybe she was
oh yeah no that's fine let's just carry
on pre-record maybe she was born without
a womb she cannot bear children no no I
know but what I'm saying she's not a
woman anymore no no no but what I was
saying is that the fact that she has the
ability there's other factors that were
involved that she cannot have a child so
what she doesn't have the ability no no
I know but you're you're woman to an
ability yes and if she doesn't have that
ability therefore she's not a woman then
right that is The Logical inference
you're going to no but what I'm saying
is following if a man has a genitalia
which is a penis he might not be able to
have a children but we do know that he
has the reproductive system that is in
place but there's something going wrong
biologically from from other means
that's stopping him from having children
however when we look we would say that
that is a biological man but it's just
because there certain factors it might
be an illness whatever it is but all
you're doing is say because that
person's got a penis he's a man and
because she's got she's a woman that's
correct what else how else do we defend
define gender well that's the problem
gender is an appearer thing you're
talking you're talking about sex
characteristics what about what about um
uh what's what you call them um uh
people got the birth defect so they got
like male and female you that's that's
why they were born like that that's
that's there there a to ter for that's
both right you but in Islam what we say
is that the organ that is active is what
determines their agenda so so if if if
they have a vagina and a penis and the
penis is the active organ we will say
that is a man so it depends other
factors but what happens when they're
four when they're what if they're four
they can't make children then can't they
four what youan if someone a child is
four they're not able to function to
make babies no no that's fine but we
woman you know but we still determin
that because at the end of life for
example we need to understand that if we
do not have these realities and these
facts where do we draw the line because
what you're doing is now you're saying I
identify as a woman now do you go to
female toilet or male toilet I am a
woman in my head I know who I am this is
about the language
thing this is about the language thing
so ultimately I have an idea in my head
and I want to get it into your head and
the only thing I've got is words yes and
the problem with words is they change
and evolve yes you know so for example
uh here's a couple of English ones so
you know the word naughty yeah nauy used
to be up there with evil okay you know
it used to be like a really strong word
you call someone naughty that's like
whoa you might as well yes you know
calling Satan or something it's up that
it's on that kind of line okay and of
course one of the problems with English
is we have multiple words that mean
roughly the same thing okay what's the
difference between a loaf and bread and
a b and a hill and a mountain and you
know and so on um a valley and a Nook
and you know it's just little little
differences nuances yeah and so we are
really learning now that what how
someone identifies isn't what's down
there it's what's in between here but
then where does where do we draw the
line because if that's the case I can
come and say I identify as someone that
who always speaks the facts therefore
you are not a
woman if I say to you I identify as an
individual who speaks nothing but facts
and my fact is that you are a man not a
woman well that's an opinion no but I
said to you up here I believe I am that
man who can tell these facts I speak
nothing but facts do you do you remember
I said about um uh the the Apple thing
yes when I state that you stole my Apple
I believe that to be a fact good I'm
wrong so it's a belief I'm wrong but
exactly so so what you believe to be a
fact yes you know it's a bit like I was
saying before exactly so a Christian
says Jesus is is is true and you say
Allah is true which one's correct you
both believe but but we have evidence
well they got evidence they believe as
evidence not really because I that's the
reason why we have a lot of dialogue
with the Christians you talked about
belief you believe up here something
like the Apple you're talking about but
we're seeing that you are wrong cuz what
you believe that you are a woman is
clear biologically and deter by other
factors that you cannot be so if we're
going to use that standard of belief
then can you believe that you are wrong
can you believe be wrong yes because my
brain does not work in the same way as
men no no but we don't know how a man's
brain works systematically clearly how
how how can we measure that we we can we
can do do you know what CAT scans are
yes you know what you know when the the
thing on the head they see the brain
light those are showing different men
tend to use one hemisphere women tend to
use both more good all right good so
good so what you've done there is now
yes we have both working okay good point
so what you've done isely I am the
middle ground we can't even determine
that what you plan is you said they use
CAT scans to see how a man's male's
brain worked and how a woman's brain
work that means that they measure
someone like they me good I fit the same
brain characteristics as women do we
don't know that I'm taking a word for
that but what I'm saying is you've
already established that there are male
and females there are some people who
say there are no male or females okay
then then what do we say to them
somebody who believes and says I don't
believe there are men and women there
are social constructs well that's what
they are okay so then how do you now how
do you believe their reality okay but
how do you believe their reality because
you said we do cat cancer no a male's
brain and a female's brain but somebody
will come and say you know I don't
believe there are men and women at all
yeah but all it's doing is verifying
things but how do you verify if somebody
comes and says I don't believe there are
men or women we are just gender neutral
well believe it or not there are
actually languages that do that it's
just a person would you accept that they
refer to a person would you accept if
someone said I'm gender
neutral no no no it's not it's not so
much about gender neutral it's just that
their language cuz remember language is
getting one idea to someone else yes
that's all it is it's just a way of
communicating ideas from one person to
another okay you're communicating
something to me I'm communicating
something to you yes so all we're doing
is comparing what we believe to be the
case but how do we come to facts and
Truth well that's the problem what you
believe to be a fact may not be true
okay but that's what I'm saying let's
let's imagine I know I know this is
going to be difficult for you because
you know you're a Believer okay you're
you're a
Muslim imagine the anidea where God
doesn't exist at all okay that you know
you die and nothing happens okay you
know there's no Heaven there's no hell
no none none of that stuff it's just you
die and you blink out of existence and
you're in the memories of your friends
and family okay you know okay what what
difference would it make it make a lot
of difference to my to my lifestyle and
the thing is that I I have evidence to
believe that what I've just stated I
believe that's what happens that's the
case Okay so but I have but you believe
something else and you know it's okay to
believe something but I can I I can
bring evidence to why that's like you're
an atheist
yes okay so I will say to you do you
accept that for example everything that
you're wearing today has a specific
pattern and it's been caused oh you're
talking about a causality you're talking
about something who's been made by
building been made would you yeah would
you accept that your glasses have been
made he used the same argument yeah so
would you believe that your glasses are
made they have a shape um uh are you
going to start doing the cosmological
argument uh I'll touch upon it but
there's different I us use the COS
argument as well the problem with Cam is
all they're saying is everything that is
made has a has a Creator yes everything
that be to exist yeah therefore the
universe began to exist universe is a
Creator therefore it was created but
doesn't say by who or by what oh yeah we
we can we say that we say by who by what
what we say is the following though is
that for example you would accept that
for example an intelligent being made
your jacket and your
glasses yes okay good are you composed
of DNA yes does DNA have information yes
information requires intelligence well
not in that case does it how tell me how
well where was the where was the
intelligence in it just a random bunch
of four chemicals no it's not not random
there are 1 billion codes in a genome
yes yes and each of these codes make
what your heart your organs each one of
them and it's only that the way it works
is it switches off and on what makes it
because it's the same DNA in your heart
but your liver looks different to your
heart it's those buttons that switch on
and off so what we see is that that's
requires that's intelligence that's a
sequence of intelligence so for example
here's the thing here's the important
thing to realize when babies are in the
womb yeah for the first few months
they're all female they all what they're
all female it depends only it's only
when they get to a certain time a
certain amount of time that they are uh
cultivating trly uh you know that that
the male code Triggers on okay good so
what what that what that means is that
it's already predetermined what the
gender are it's a matter of time where
the code is okay inactive but here's the
thing that's important okay we have all
the different organs and they have a
code for those orans so so there a code
let's use let's use an analogy okay of
um a Lego set yes you buy the Lego set
it comes with the instruction you build
it as it says yes okay those are the and
you know effective we can say the
instructions put that piece to that
piece to that piece to that piece look
like that she that is the code the DNA
code okay now for someone like me is
that your no okay um for someone like me
yeah
isn't it possible that where the liver
is is perfectly fine coded yeah but um
instead of red yeah they were green okay
the pieces of the Lego set okay so my
brain yeah had a different structure the
code was a little bit different are are
you telling are you telling me that that
that that's what makes you a female or
are you making I'm I'm using an analogy
okay to say that my brain works
differently okay but how does that make
you a female well cuz different woman
that their brains work a bit different
to The Other Woman it doesn't make them
a different speci of woman but no no no
it's not a different species it's just
that in my brain the code that said you
know like let's let's use two elements
of it right we got two components okay
one of it is the genitals and the
genital the the Lego set was yep that's
male one yeah but my brain had the
female version okay we say you know why
this important to God Almighty because
we believe God cannot make that mistake
so we say for example this why it's
important when I was talking about God
almighty
it's important to have that relationship
with God that's why I say to you if we
composed of no God cannot make a mistake
the mistake is within ourselves no no
sorry let me let me state that yeah why
is it a mistake because why do you
consider it a mistake not what God
wanted this is what we say we say that
God Almighty there's objective morality
so morality doesn't change by human
beings decisions because otherwise
that's where we be for example do you go
to female toilet or male toilet oh I
just go to the toilet I tend to go I go
to female toilets when I'm out okay but
that for for example a lot of people
will have a lot of concerns with that
cuz if I'm saying to my daughter let me
tell you why not that I'm not saying
that I'm not saying that you're going to
do anything but it's a matter of there
is a to me to my belief without any
offense a biological man is in the
toilet with my argument my daughter
who's 101 for that matter now I'm seeing
in that aspect imagine if you had a
child okay and you've have you have a
daughter and I identify as a woman and
you send her to the toilet and there is
a biological man out there who has the
ability who has all M or reproduction
organ and could potentially if the brain
just switches for whatever reason they
could they could choose to use and me I
want to know that there are females in
that toilet now if I know there is a
female there but is actually a man to me
that is violating my rights sorry I'm
not a man though that's the problem but
that's what that's what you believe
though this
is reality what's in about it is why
would you make an assumption that
because of genitals therefore I'm
dangerous no no I'm I'm not I'm not I'm
not I'm not saying that I'm saying
potentially you're in the wrong you're
in the wrong place it's like me can I be
in a woman's woman's toilet H what would
happen if I go to toilet hang on the
thing to bear in mind yeah is you're
basically suggest the the you're making
it an inference that because I was born
with certain genitals therefore I
possibly could be a danger I wouldn't
the number do you know how many PE out
of you know like the last at least 50
years do you know how many transend
people someone in toilet there there's a
lot of cases there's there's a man who
got arrested who went who identified as
a woman no no there isn't there was a
woman who a man who identified as a
woman went into the woman's prison and
raped multiple inmates so what I'm
saying is there are many cases yeah
there's there's many cases what I'm
saying is this like in nurseries why do
you always see females working instead
of men thing to bear in mind but can you
ask me a question hang on this is
important because you brought up that
person yeah okay that
person committed rape before they went
when they were a guy yes
so it wasn't because they used your card
hang to do just to do more think about
it okay it wasn't because they were
trans that they did this thing is
because they were
rapist you I understand but what I'm
saying is they use that card like back
in the days people I'm going to use and
I apologize I really do apologize so you
know the people you know Muslim
terrorists have things and stuff like
that does that mean I should think of
your suspect because of the color of
your skin or you know you got a beard or
you a Muslim if if for example
I believe in judging people for what
they do have you been we disagree okay
we clearly disagree but you have not
been offensive to me 100% I don't want
to be offensive I'm not here to be
offensive to you I want to have a
dialogue with you but what I see is that
I believe the reason why you're thinking
the way you're thinking is because you
don't have a relation with God Almighty
I believe if you had a relation with God
Almighty cuz what's happening is when
you don't have God in your life you are
bound to worship something and what
you're doing is you maybe came to a
point in your life where you thought you
know what I don't want to be a man let
me be honest with you being man is is
quite hard there was that woman who
Believers that do really awful things in
the name of their Rel no no what I'm
saying is this what I'm saying is this
and they're awful yes of course but what
we're saying is the we're not going to
judge everybody because few of ter
people yes what we're saying is that in
order to find Ultimate happiness and
serenity and peace you having a
relationship with God Almighty will fix
that and make you understand why you're
here you embrace yourself cuz look
there's a lot of things people want to
be there are Muslim men who want to go
and sleep around Islam says no we don't
believe that my desires is going to
control me rather I have to control my
desires otherwise the you can never stop
today you will say I'm a woman tomorrow
I'll say I'm a piano somebody else will
come and say I'm a tree where do you
stop silly thing why is that a silly
thing this is very why can one don't
identify as treats no no there is there
there was a man who married a piano so
what I'm saying is why do you Bel little
there that's just being that's just
something that's really you're you're
basically bringing up outliers as if
that's the same thing and it's not but
they can say the same to you trying to
compare two things like why do you deny
their reality like for example p
why doesn't the lgbqt community accept
pedophiles why don't they accept People
Inc what's LGBT people do accept they
don't accept now these These are these
and and I I believe they shouldn't what
I'm saying is that that this man comes
and says I was born to have attraction
to minors the majority of piles are
people like yourself I don't mean Muslim
I just mean men okay you know most
pedoph are men I mean I mean
most but it doesn't mean to say that all
men are pedop no b bs B because we judge
people about what they do not not what
they believe or whatever you know you
believe you're a Muslim you believe I'm
not going to say that this person is
terrorist because understand but there's
certain reality that incest what's your
views on incest I I think it's wrong but
that's my person no no but on what basis
if if if a brother and sister has
protected sex why is that wrong no no if
they have protected sex why is it wrong
it still can lead to BU effects no if
they use if they use condom you say I
mean you know I don't really you know as
long as no one's being hurt okay good so
then so then you're okay with a brother
and sister having sex a mother and
daughter and a father and that's the
thing CU that's where do you draw your
line where you say morality this where
it stops well that's the problem it's
slippery slopy isn't it but the point is
this where do that go to exactly that's
what we're saying but that's what we're
saying Laura like like like what I'm
saying is I'm I'm saying that if you
have a relationship with God Almighty it
will answer all your questions cuz we
believe God doesn't make a mistake we're
human beings we are bound by our
societal pressures and other factors so
what I'm saying is these are the things
that's LED you which I believe to think
that you are a female when you're you're
not well I am that's what you believe
but again it goes back to the Bel system
but you know have you read the Quran
before uh yes I haven't actually got a
copy of can I give you one sure sure
yeah thank you and I appreciate it Ian I
have read bit trust me one thing is that
we need to subit what was it I I don't
know if it's a part of the Coran where
it's one of the ades or something but
it's basically um if you def decide to
divorce your wife yeah if she's pregnant
you got to look after her yeah you have
to for a certain amount yeah you have to
after it yeah I think things like that
are you know of course of they're rules
for society that's the thing the
objective reality all these things are
just rules for a community a group of
people that believe this thing
Christians believe their thing you know
um I went to Japan last year and you
know they got Buddhists and Shinto as
well look I I would I would say read the
Quan way um here fun thing when I went
to Japan I went to a Buddhist temple in
uh in Nagano and I have touched the key
to Paradise okay interesting you know do
you want me to tell you that it's very
short don't wor okay so um went to this
place in Nago and I paid some money to
do the service and it was just it was a
curious
because we got no we're going now we'll
finish now one minute you just telling
the story we'll finish is the live
totally gone I restarted okay is is on
is this going on YouTube or something
yeah yeah yeah you'll have to tell me
your group so I yeah sure sure sure sure
yeah yeah you tell me a story about the
Japan name CU I would be really
disappointed with you if you edited it
no I promise you I I give you my word
it's going to be from the beginning to
the end um anyway so um you went to
Japan so I went to Japan so I paid some
money and did the service just some
chanting and some sticks a bong kind of
thing and then afterwards they led us to
a tunnel under the temping yeah and it
was uh and it's pitch black yeah so you
go down these steps yeah and Pitch Black
and there sign you have to keep your
hand on the wall so you don't bump into
things and uh so I went with about a
group of people like 15 of us and it was
really hard walking in the dark cuz
you're worried about ping into a person
in front of you for the seventh time
yeah um and so it's saying that the key
to Paradise um is is you know around
waist height so I went around and I
could hear squeaking noise obviously
other people found
but I couldn't find it and the symbolism
behind it is it's the desent into hell
now it's not like fire and Satan and
burning and torture it it's just
Blackness nothingness okay okay similar
to what I believe you die nothing that's
it it's nothing you know but anyway so
it's nothing uh it's just Blackness no
torment no anything and so uh but if you
touch the key it's the key to paradise
and when you die you just go to heav or
go to paradise I don't know whether they
consider it of Heaven in a similar way
to the you know uh the abrahamic gods um
and then um uh and then when you come
out it's like bring being reborn that's
symbolizing so I I couldn't find it and
I went to a temp another building it was
a priest I said what's the tunnel thing
about and he explain what I told you and
he said I said well I couldn't find the
key you couldn't I said no you know he
said well the sign say it's a waste side
I said yeah my waste a lot higher than
he was cuz he was only that that all so
next time I'm wondering I'm going like
that all the way down I found it in the
end okay I just thought that was an
interesting it it is it thank you I
appreciate I mean read the Quran have a
look was your Al my name is my I don't
have a but on YouTube
Al on YouTube the prophet sallallah alai
wasallam said the one who builds a Masid
for the sake of Allah Allah will build
for him a similar house in Jenna we want
to establish an amazing Masid for the
sake of Allah subhana tala in the
country of Norway one of the most
northern countries of the world if you
donate for the sake of Allah to
establish this Masjid then he subhah wa
ta'ala will give you the reward
inshallah tala for every single person
who becomes a Muslim in this Masjid for
every single person who starts
practicing the dean from the dawa that
we give in this Masjid when they pray
their salawat when they fast in the
month of Ramadan when they give in
charity every single Good Deed that they
do you will inshallah get the reward for
that if you donate something small maybe
$100 maybe $50 or whatever you can for
the sake of Allah subhana wa ta'ala and
Allah subhah wa taala said
[Music]
click on the link and donate now for the
sake of Allah subhana wa tala and share
the video it's absolutely free and you
will get extra reward for everyone else
participate in this amazing project